[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
any suggestion that i am not complying
with requests or orders or demands or
search warrants about my phone that's
that's a lie days after that claim from
alec baldwin santa fe authorities talk
about the actor's phone and whether he's
handed it over plus i'm perfectly calm
all the time and
he really stresses me out the results of
an independent investigation into a
traffic stop with gabby petito weeks
before her murder and this is not the
rittenhouse case i know judge schrader i
consider judge schrader a friend of mine
i have never
required the state or told the state how
to refer to somebody when they're on the
stand a high-profile wisconsin case
hanging over the upcoming murder trial
of theodore edgecombe but first this
investigation is geared towards as if
harmony is still alive new questions
about a state agency's involvement with
harmony montgomery more than two years
after she disappeared long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the stepmother of a missing new
hampshire girl faces new welfare charges
as a search continues for seven-year-old
harmony montgomery law and crime's angel
levy is here with information about the
new charges in question surrounding a
state agency's handling of the case
anjanette
brian prosecutors in new hampshire
dropped one welfare chart fraud charge
against kayla montgomery but they've
added other charges including a felony
theft by deception count now kayla
montgomery has been in jail since last
week she's accused of accepting food
stamp benefits for harmony montgomery
after she claims harmony's dad sent her
to live with her biological mother in
massachusetts back in 2019 but
prosecutors say kayla montgomery
continued to use the food stamp money
for about 16 months after harmony left
the home kayla montgomery claims she
tried to have harmony removed from the
family's food stamp account now kayla
montgomery's husband adam montgomery is
in jail facing a second degree assault
charge he's accused of punching harmony
in the face back in 2019. family members
said montgomery was physically abusive
with harmony no one has seen harmony
since late 2019 her mother reported her
missing last month after not being able
to locate her daughter now manchester
new hampshire's police chief alan
aldenberg held a briefing he said the
reward in this case for information that
leads to harmony montgomery is now up to
a hundred and four thousand dollars and
this comes as the chief answer questions
about police calls that happened in the
past at harmony's last known address
chief oldenburg answered those questions
about the police department's
involvement with harmony and it was
noted that the department had actually
contacted new hampshire's department of
children's youth and family services
about harmony now there are serious
questions about how harmony's case was
handled by that agency
chief oldenburg answered questions about
the police department's contact with the
little girl
i'm extremely confident i will stand
behind the work of this police
department that led us up to 1227 and i
stand even further behind it
from 1227 to today um
i'm not going to point fingers in any
other agency because i don't think it's
going to do the investigation any good
i'm standing in front of you
okay
i'm the one answering questions so
if that doesn't
paint the picture
i'm going to leave it at that
now i exchanged emails with the new
hampshire department of children's youth
and family services last week the
spokesperson said they couldn't comment
on this case citing confidentiality
reasons i followed up with a second
email asking more questions and that
email was not returned meanwhile kayla
montgomery will be back in court to
answer to these new charges on january
24th brian
thanks ange joining us today is legal
analyst kirk nermey and terry austin
kirk one charge gone and three in its
place for caleb montgomery the charges
are similar but different how so
yeah well one of the most obvious
differences is going to stand out to
people is we went from a misdemeanor to
a felony and it shows that the state now
is wanting to turn up the heat on miss
montgomery but of course it means more
jail time prison time that sort of thing
but the other thing it does that people
might not think about is if somebody's
convicted of a felony they're not
eligible for some of the social services
the programs especially if they
defrauding those programs moving on in
the future so she wouldn't be eligible
for some of those services and all that
is to turn up the heat under the theory
that they think she knows something
about perhaps what harmony's father did
or what happened to harmony in general
and maybe it creates incentives for her
to actually give that information
because they can remove some of those
collateral consequences you're talking
about if she plays ball terry as this
case evolves with new information going
uh coming to light how does it affect
the search for harmony and the cases
against kayla and adam
well brian the more information they
uncover the better we'll be able to
determine exactly what happened to
harmony and the better they'll be able
to prosecute the cases against the
defendants but i think the fbi should be
called into this and i understand that
the police has spoken to the fbi but
they've not yet responded to the case
and may not they need resources here so
they can investigate adam and caleb
montgomery but also the biological mom
and also the department of children's
services for both in my opinion
massachusetts and new hampshire now
angela what do we know about the
investigation so far into harmony's
disappearance
tight-lipped about the investigation but
we know over the last weekend
police had gone to the last known
address of harmony montgomery she hadn't
lived there and neither had her parents
in some time her father hadn't lived
there but they searched that property
what they found what they were looking
for is not exactly clear obviously any
evidence of harmony they said they're
trying to find her
alive and hopeful to find her alive but
they're obviously looking for anything
that can lead them
to any information about what happened
to her
and as angenette said they are looking
for more and more information of course
they have that reward but i believe you
said a thousand a hundred thousand and
four dollars and if you have information
about uh
young montgomery please send that
information thank you all
in new mexico a teenager faces attempted
murder charges after police say she gave
birth and left her newborn in a dumpster
after wrapping him in garbage bags over
the weekend hobbs police arrested 18
year old high school student alexis
avila after 9-1-1 callers found the baby
while dumps are diving police say
surveillance video shows a villa
drive up to the dumpster and place a
garbage bag inside of it the baby now
recovering in a texas hospital's
neonatal intensive care unit spent six
hours inside the dumpster at a press
conference this week officials explained
what information avila revealed after
her arrest
during the interview she said she was
not aware that she was pregnant until
january 6 2022
when she sought medical attention for
abdominal pain and constipation
she explained that on friday january 7th
she was experiencing stomach pain
and unexpectedly gave birth
she further explained that she panicked
did not know what to do or who to call
she stated that she then cut the
umbilical cord
wrapped the baby in a towel and placed
the baby inside a white trash bag
containing some trash
and then inside a larger black trash bag
she explained that she then started
driving around until she decided to
place the baby inside
a green colored dumpster
near the jc penny store
alexis was asked by investigators what
she thought would eventually happen to
the baby by placing him inside of a
plastic bag and dumping him alexis
remained silent and could not answer
wednesday a judge ordered a villa be
placed on house arrest at her parents
home she's also required to wear a gps
tracker
still ahead on law and crime daily the
kyle renthouse case still lingers in
wisconsin where judges push up against
rulings made in kenosha county
but first more questions answered in
brian laundry and gabby patino's august
traffic stop what officials say officers
did wrong after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
queen of england's strip song prince
andrew of his royal titles as a united
states federal judge denies the motion
to dismiss the sexual assault lawsuit
against him on thursday queen elizabeth
ii removed prince andrew from his
military affiliations and royal
patronages a statement from buckingham
palace reads in part quote the duke of
york will continue not to undertake any
public duties and is defending his case
as a private citizen this week a judge
has denied a motion to dismiss the suit
against prince andrew filed by virginia
dufrey who is also a jeffrey epstein and
elaine maxwell accuse her drew frey says
the british royals sexually assaulted
her when she was trafficked to him by
epstein and maxwell when she was 17.
prince andrew argued a 2009 settlement
drew frey made with epstein barred her
from suing him jeffrey accepted a payout
of 500 000
from epstein and agreed it would be
confidential the lawsuit now moves into
the discovery phase which involves
taking depositions if the case is not
settled it could move to trial later
this year
and months after responding to the brian
laundry and gallipoli domestic
disturbance in utah an independent
investigation recommends officers be
placed on probation for the response to
the incident
it was the body camera footage seen
around the world showing an august 12
2021 traffic stop of unnoticeably upset
gabby petito and brian laundry officers
pulled the pair over after seeing their
van speed up and run into a curb the
parent later told officers they had been
in a fight saying potito hit laundry
first officers told the couple petito
must be arrested under utah statute but
later agreed to not charge her when she
agreed to spend the night away from
laundry an independent review of the
traffic stop found officers neglected to
cite gabby patino for domestic violence
and made several unintentional mistakes
petito and laundry's story captivated
the nation when she was reported missing
in early september her body was found
weeks later in grand teton national park
officials determined her cause of death
to be strangulation brian long's remains
were found in a florida reserve in
october his death was ruled a suicide
let's bring in legal analysts kirk
nermey and terry ozil to discuss the
latest in the gabby potato and brian
laundry case terry several unintentional
mistakes is how the responding officers
are being described does this mean any
punishment beyond probation
listen i don't think they should have
even gotten probation so i hope they
don't get more punishment beyond that
the report says that they neglected
their duty by failing to make an arrest
as far as gabby petito is concerned but
i'm not sure they saw the same video i
saw if anyone should have been arrested
it would have been brian laundry and i
say that because she was clearly upset
she had a scratch on her face and
frankly that might have been domestic
violence and she as we all know ended up
being murdered by brian laundry so
frankly i think what the officers did
was reasonable and you know it was a
mild case who would have known it would
have ended up the way it did
now kirk if these let's call them
well-meaning officers made this mistake
does that not suggest that there could
be problems at the department level and
how do those get addressed
well
i'm going to disagree with terry here
because it seemed pretty obvious under
the state law and under all department
policies that
gabby even though we can look
retrospectively and see her as the
victim in this situation should have
been arrested the report's extensive
it's over
it's over 100 pages and ultimately i do
think it is going to bring changes
throughout the entire department it
should be used as a training tool
because while these officers might have
been well-meaning and not wanting to
arrest gabby and doing everything they
could not to arrest gabby maybe
maybe had they arrested her the whole
course of cha events would have changed
and
that's not their call to make it's their
policy to follow all right we'll see how
those department changes and maybe also
individual changes occur like we said
the officers are on probation will
continue to follow the story as it
unfolds coming up on law and crime daily
was the russ movie set shooting a tragic
accident or sabotage what the movie's
armorers alleges in a new lawsuit plus a
man in wisconsin is set to stand trial
for the murder of a prominent attorney
how the monumental kyle renthouse case
has taken center stage and theodore
edgecombe's coming trial
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and grind daily
advocates call for a new judge in the
theodore edgeco murder trial in
wisconsin this after the defense says
judge david koprowski
has shown bias against his case
edgcomb is accused of killing milwaukee
immigration attorney jason clearman
during what police are calling a road
rage incident it happened in september
of 2020 clearman and his wife were
driving and edgecombe was riding his
bike in the opposite direction
clearman's wife says she had to swerve
to miss hitting edgecomb video not made
public yet shows edgecombe reached into
the car and punched clearman through the
open window at a red light the next part
is also captured on security video the
couple follows edgecomb around a corner
that's when clearman gets out of the car
and edgecomb shoots him prosecutors say
edgecombe fled the state and was
arrested months later he is now claiming
self-defense at a motions hearing on
monday the defense argued that calling
clearman a victim goes against its
self-defense argument
the next motion in lemony uh
asked that the state be precluded from
using language that assumes the
defendant committed a crime by shooting
the deceased such language such as the
use of the word victim
or that the defendant committed a cold
crime or that officers arrived at the
crime scene is
being objected to one could argue that
alleged crimes were committed by
the clearmans as well in terms of
reckless endangering safety or going on
with the weapon disorderly conduct
things of that nature so that's another
basis for our request is if if they're
going to use those terms
then i think it would be fair for the
defense
during instruction for homicide
if the court and the court knows this it
states
the defendant did
cause the death of and then in the jury
instruction it says insert name of
victim
this is a homicide he's a victim
right right let me jump in it's a
homicide he's a victim whether he was
the victim of a self-defense
situation or he was a victim of a
reckless homicide is what the jury is to
determine
galvalgabo coverage of this trial begins
next tuesday here on lawn crime network
let's bring in legal analyst kirk nermey
and co-host terry austin to discuss the
coming edgecombe trial terry as you see
these motions being decided do you see
this case being more difficult for one
side or the other other before it even
starts
i actually think it's going to be more
difficult for the defendant here because
now he has to face this intentional
homicide and the reckless homicide so
he's going to have to show that his
deadly use of force was reasonable
frankly and i think that's going to be
difficult or the prosecution's going to
have to show that it's unreasonable and
you know when you look at the facts of
the case we know that there was an
exchange of words but we also know that
edgecombe punched clearman through the
window and we know ultimately that
clearman got out there was a
confrontation and edgecombe shot him so
was that reasonable was it intentional i
think it's going to be hard for the
defense now kirk judge denying all of
your emotions is biased here i thought
that was just a part of being a public
defender but could these be grounds for
an actual removal of a judge
well you know it typically is right us
criminals former public defenders talk
about you know having an extra
prosecutor in the courtroom he's just
wearing over here she's just wearing a
robe and we're seeing some of that here
and it's not just the denial of the
motion but it's the tone you can see
this judge step in interrupt the
prosecution and go after the defense
attorneys for even raising certain
issues and he says he's not going to
help you know uh
constrain the state on how they try
their case but he's certainly doing it
with the defense so he's not coming
across as an impartial referee but
rather a biased party so i understand so
if i was at that defense table i would
be looking at any mechanism i had under
the rules to remove him as a judge in my
case not just because of the rulings but
because of the demeanor and the fact
that he's not going to give my client a
fair trial i mean when i think about
this case i think about that picture of
kyle renthouse looking over the shoulder
of judge schrader as they're looking at
exhibits and how different that scene is
compared to what's going on with
theodore edgecombe i agree kirk the
defense may have an argument here that's
a little different when we come back
conflicting reports about a search
warrant for alec baldwin's cell phone
the actor says he's complying but new
mexico police say they haven't received
the phone the latest on the rush
shooting investigation after the break
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily new
developments in the alec baldwin russ
movie set shooting investigation out of
new mexico days after the actor
proclaims he is cooperating with the
investigation the santa fe police
department says it is still does not
have alec baldwin's cell phone
as law on crime daily reporter baldr
posted a video to his instagram last
week saying it was a quote lie that he
was not cooperating with the
investigation in handing over his cell
phone on thursday the santa fe police
department released a statement saying
he'd issued a search warrant for the
actor's cell phone nearly one month ago
all this comes as the film's armorer
hannah gutierrez reid sues the supplier
of ammunition and guns for the film set
gutierrez reid accuses the supplier of
giving them boxes of ammunition
containing live rounds but they should
have only been dummy rounds
in october baldwin fired a gun on the
set killing cinematographer helena
hutchins and injuring director joel
souza
kirk the armorer claimed sabotage saying
that real bullets were mixed in with the
dummy rounds what sort of outcome could
we see in that lawsuit
well i think we're going to get a couple
of things you know obviously i think the
armor is starting to feel the heat of
this investigation ramping up what's
going to be found out so she's looking
for someone else to blame i don't know
what kind of damages she would have to
sue this company in terms of civil
damages but here she goes she's trying
to deflect blame and i think we're going
to find out in the
discovery process of this you know the
the company the supplier is going to
deny that they were the source of these
live ammunition and that could open up a
whole new can of worms when this
investigation goes forward who put those
things there and if they can prove that
they didn't do it that's going to turn
the lens of suspicion on to somebody
else someone on the set it's gonna be
very interesting to see how the
discovery process works out terry things
aren't adding up baldwin says he's
cooperating but the santa fe police
department say they requested his phone
back in december so what can we believe
you know what brian the age-old adage is
true actions speak louder than words and
baldwin is claiming that he wants to
cooperate and thus far he has been
cooperating but the fact that he doesn't
want to turn over his phone means that
he is not fully cooperating he has to be
in fear that showing the phone is going
to demonstrate that perhaps he does have
some sort of criminal liability here and
even worse i think he's worried about
the fact that it could show that he has
some sort of responsibility as far as
civil liability so he needs to turn over
that phone yeah we'll see how that goes
as it continues thank you both and thank
you for joining us here at law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you